hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video today we're gonna be talking about
monster on a world again and in specific
today is gonna be five beginner tips for
new players
now that Monster Hunter is starting to
release on consoles and PC in the coming
months a lot of new players are gonna be
hopping into this game not knowing what
to do I for sure I'm one of them this is
my first ever Monster Hunter game but
throughout the day I've been playing a
lot of this game and I've learned some
really neat tips that you would
definitely like to know so let's get
started
tip number one is to harvest and track
everything and Monster Hunter your main
objective is to track hunt and kill the
monster but don't forget about
everything along the way even if you
know where the monster is still grab the
footprint tracks while you're chasing it
because if you level up this the
tracking of a certain monster you can
automatically have it spawn on the map
with a marker without having it to find
it the next time you decide to hunt it
again for parts also grab the skin of a
monster once it's dead so you can craft
a better armor to keep you in the fight
longer and as for harvesting and finding
mushrooms and herbs those will give you
potions to who yourself or cure poison
so those are a definite grab as well
number two and I cannot stress this
enough is that every weapon in this game
is viable
the devs for Monster Hunter World wanted
every weapon to be used so that you can
choose your own play style without
having to switch to another weapon
because the one you like is bad and
there's another one that's better yes it
might seem like some are not as good
like the range weapons aren't so good
but use correctly they are an absolute
brutal force this game has a learning
curve so you're gonna need to know your
favorite weapon and gun just because it
is key to your survival
number three is study the monster
monster on our world won't hold their
hand and some of the fights in this game
will get tough especially if you're
alone yes you're going to die constantly
that's just how the game is but
especially the monsters you haven't
faced before so take these deaths as a
lesson study the monsters movesets you
know what moves will come each time you
fight him for example go to a short
distance and see what moves the monster
will do whether it be a sweep a bite a
slash or any combination of those and
then learn that timing within enough
time you'll be able to get it down no
problem number 4 is to make sure to go
on expeditions expeditions basically are
areas of the map that you've already
discovered but you're going there
without a quest without the quest
there's no time constraint no feign
limit you can die as many times you want
to take as long as you want you're free
to do whatever you want use this
opportunity to
other monsters in that area without the
time constraint and then you need those
scales and bones from another monster go
farm it from the plants and mushrooms
around the area to get some more herbs
and potions and stuff like that if your
load - crafter for the next fight that
you're coming up against and then my
last tip and probably the most important
one to me is to make sure to check up on
everyone in Astrea
I may have pronounced that wrong but
Esther is probably the most important
place and Monster Hunter there's so much
stuff you need to do and check up on
that it's very crucial so let's go over
that exclamation points on the map are
for people who have a quest for you and
when completed can yield some nice
rewards the provisions Mershon in the
middle of the map will buy your stuff as
well as give you the availability to
purchase his own inventory which has
slinger ammo bow arrows and heavy gun
bones as well as some potions antidotes
meats and other necessities for upcoming
fight at the research center you can
complete bounties like gathering for
honey for a small reward complete
deliveries and manage investigations to
get seek rewards and money for these the
ecologist and probably one of the most
important ones he should be talked to
routinely so you can update the tracking
of monsters so that they'll be easier to
catch the next time you hunt which we
mentioned in my first tip the botanist
will harvest a mushroom bug or herb and
continue to produce more I for one I
recommend using the herbs since potions
aren't absolute necessity when fighting
monsters talk to him use the use the
herb you can even fertilize it to make
it grow faster and you'll get tons in no
time next up is the canteen with the
little cat that's the chef he can fill
you up on food and gain extra boost like
more damage damage resistance or more
stamina recovery for a shorter time
definitely a good idea to grab this
before a quest or an expedition or if
you want you can use the canteen
during a quest at the campfires before
the mission as well and then lastly is
the smithy the Smith is gonna be your
best friend he's gonna start making you
new weapons and armor for you as well as
upgrading your current set of gear if
you have the right tools if you want to
upgrade new weapons or if you want to
get new weapons and upgrade others
you're gonna need the correct tools like
skin and scales from other monsters for
example if you want pukey puke ease type
set you're gonna need to kill him more
and get his scales and feathers and
stuff like that
so you can use that type of scale and
armor to make basically weapons and
armor out of his own skin it's kind of
creepy but it all
rewards different types of effects and
type of resistances depending on what
you feel suits your needs if you use an
insect glaive or a bow gun the Smith
will also allow you to make
modifications to each of those weapon
types like getting a different type of
bow attachment like a shield or insect
glaive which is it which would basically
give you a different type of insect
which will give you a different type of
effect and that is going to be my five
tips for monster hunter world especially
for beginners if you guys didn't please
sure to give it a like this was a little
bit of a interesting video and might get
a little bit confusing if you have any
questions definitely hit me up in the
comments I will gladly answer those for
you or you can go back in the video to a
certain spot and you can just re-watch
that part either way it works so
subscribe for free new I'm starting to
post a lot more monster on our world
since the game has just released I got
tons of other video ideas coming out so
please be sure to stick stick around for
those my other Monster Hunter videos
gonna be popping up on screen I had a
mounting is an absolute necessity within
the game so that's definitely a
worthwhile check out and with that guys
hope you have a great rest of your day
and peace out